going back to the YouTuber scam thing or
the YouTuber comments again thing I've
got an interesting email the other day
all right so one of my fans saw that uh
saw that there was a scammer on my
comment section like you know I had
reply to every comment saying you've won
X or you have won a raffle or something
like that so he decides what if uh what
if we try to what if what happens if I
try to pursue this and see and see how
deep the rabbit hole goes that's right
yeah so uh so I get this email just like
detailing what like the messages he sent
and the messages that he got back and
everything like that so well there was
this guy impersonating me on one of my
comment section it was it was kind of
like a bot and uh the bot just said you
have won a PS5 please contact this yeah
you've please contact this email for
more details right uh and so he didn't
he doesn't send me the entire
conversation through he just the
highlights yeah he sends me the
highlights of just so if they get to a
stage where he's talking to this person
on WhatsApp right
yeah if you're on WhatsApp you're being
yeah yeah yeah so so this guy who's
impersonating me right he's he
he doesn't even name himself gig hug so
it's my profile picture and everything
right yeah but the name is the gig up
oh he took your email right how are you
gonna let him get away with it
so it's not good it's the gigguk the
actual game holy [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah I better
take the seat up
I've already taken the anime
but like it gets it gets interesting
when you know you get it possible he
plays along for like a little bit and
then he just kind of calls him out just
being like this is this seems like a
scam I'm I'm feeling a bit nervous about
this now tell me if this sounds like me
at all
um you don't have to doubt the process
I have vowed to God never to cheat or
let anyone down on this and I have keep
this promise for so long without
disobeying the Lord Our God that sounds
like you yeah
this is like this is monk can't speak is
this please tell me that's an all caps
it sounds like it needs to be in all
caps okay okay Carry On and it's just
like beginning to get agitated because
it's an insult Tome Me by suggesting
this is a scam and then then he goes
please pay to these methods as soon as
poss as soon as possible Bitcoin
deposits
I don't even know what Zella is and it's
just and it's just saying I'm encour I'm
doing this to encourage my fans out
there to achieve their dreams and also
encourage them with the PS5 if you don't
me then you can go I can't force you to
trust me
what I will stand for to achieved been
unreal
wait could you repeat that could you
repeat that lesson okay what I will
stand to achieve to been unreal been
unreal yeah God I want this to be a copy
Pastor so bad I want this to be a new
copy pasta well I will stand to achieve
being unreal what the [ __ ] does that
mean are they sending pictures like
family or something like this yeah the
[ __ ] is this they're sending pictures of
like fans who have won this PS5
basically but I think it's just it just
looks like someone's Ebay listing
basically
so uh who whoever whoever went down that
rabbit hole You you were the Giga Chad
for the day oh my God I did people who
waste scammers time yeah yeah you're the
true heroes just seeing scammers get
enraged just I mean it makes my makes me
makes me smile yeah do you doubt me do
you doubt me being unreal
I swear to my heart I got our Lord and
savior Gods what this is not a scam
are you doubting
I'll tell you yeah
I don't know yeah because
yeah it's it's weird because like
people will always find new innovative
ways to scam but it's just like and then
there's this [ __ ] and then there's this
well that's the thing like a lot of
these scammers like we've talked about
like Jim Browning before and how I was
exposed like scammers in India and stuff
like that but I'm just like
I don't know too much about it is
they're just like not enough laws
preventing this stuff in that country or
is it not enough enforcement enough
enforcement I think generally like the
enforcement is lacks and you know in in
other countries
um yeah some some areas police can be uh
you know they look the other way if you
give them a little cheap payment or two
right I think a lot of places they
struggle with you know because these
places make so much money yeah so it's
hard to you know to get the government
to keep taking them down and also they
to be fair they they do get taken down
fairly often but then they just move
like it's really easy to just make this
operation anywhere right yeah just get
an office space with PCS boom you're set
up yeah and you probably make enough
money to cover any of the relocating
costs yeah yeah it's tough I guess so
easy money easy well like
how many times have you been like have
you ever like talked to someone who's
like phoned you on like like a scam
phone uh well I don't know what they're
called like
I mean I used to do a lot of videos
calling them oh yeah you did didn't you
yeah and they were just getting raged
but like they're really so dude they're
really good at knowing when you're not
gonna like bite say just block your
number right if they even have a feeling
that you're not like participating they
just so you that's why you see other
people who call them up on Twitch and
stuff and who make content they do they
really play the long game they like they
are on like kit burger if you've ever
seen his stuff he's on calls sometimes
for like eight hours on one call just
[ __ ] with them like leading them on
the entire time and then finally at the
end they get that big payoff yeah he
finally reveals he's been [ __ ] with
them yeah and they lose it and it's like
hilarious because you're just like the
dedication is unreal right but dude I
didn't have that mine were always like
two minutes because they realized I was
[ __ ] with them right like right away
and they blocked my number so I had to
keep making new numbers constantly and
then calling them back and then they
would just hang up right away eight
hours wait who is this guy again yeah
his stuff's really good okay you've
Definitely Maybe seen one of two videos
and you recommended he's really funny
really good at it he pretends to be a
grandma with a voice change
okay okay I think I have seen I've seen
Clips so that's pretty convincing like
yeah yeah yeah
um so yeah he does that for like all day
on stream [ __ ] is unreal it's Jesus is
nice it's insane yeah that's an easy
eight hour stream man yeah honestly it's
kind of crazy itself it's awesome I mean
anything that you can do to waste these
dudes time and then hey you can also get
paid off of it yeah yeah man [ __ ] yeah
man I won't I want the uh the amount of
people getting paid to [ __ ] over
scammers to outweigh people being
scammed yeah
we're so far away that would be a
perfect Society wouldn't it yeah yeah I
don't know I mean like yeah it's um it
sucks I mean hopefully the the they get
better in forcing the laws over there
yeah fixing it it sucks but you know the
people who live there also hate these
[ __ ] like they yeah yeah yeah yeah
I've got a local populations so many
people local people would just be like
these people do not represent us
actually give them a bad name yeah yeah
exactly exactly right America is really
bad as well I know every American friend
I have they're like yeah I got like four
scam calls today it's like what yeah
yeah what yeah in Japan you've got zero
it's in the UK you maybe get one every
now in the UK you get like okay the the
weirdest thing I find is like the scam
calls where it's not even a person on
the other end yeah you just get an
automated message you just get an
automated message right you have one A
PS5 yeah so okay here's the thing though
right that obviously to any sane person
or any normal person you're like this is
[ __ ] dumb I'm just not gonna call
this up but in their mind if somebody
Falls for that and they call back this
is your perfect candidate to scam yeah
because a [ __ ] stupid ass robot just
told them they're going to jail and
they're believing it right so now this
is like perfect this is the exact kind
of person who will then give me his bank
information yeah yeah so that's the
problem is that we often think it's like
and that's where the shame comes into it
right is that it's so stupid in in our
mind that you could fall for this that
then these people feel so ashamed they
don't want to say anything and they
don't want to get help or have you know
or admit to it so you know there's that
cycle where I think people need to be a
bit more sympathetic towards people get
scammed I think
um because I just feel like if it's
going to improve in the conversation
around it's going to improve because
nobody talks about it nobody talks to
they I nearly fell for a scam yeah no
one wants to admit that they well nearly
fell for something so I feel like the
dialogue needs to be a bit more open
about it yeah yeah I mean I I can't
remember the last time I fell for a scam
but I remember it was it was it was a
phishing email
um kind of kind of very similar to you
and then I've realized it was you know
some moments where you you do something
and it's like me instant immediately
immediate immediately grip like yeah
like playing chess you move the queen
and you just immediately realize you've
landed as soon as you like Let It Go
yeah that happened to me as soon as I
press the submit button to like my
password and emails and luckily I S
because I submitted it because I
realized it right away I managed to get
time to like change everything like
right there and there
um because God forbid having my username
and password is something that is very
you know as as my job has gotten more
and more on the internet my username and
password has gotten only more and more
secure you know yeah of course as it's
going on yeah man I you imagine you'd
spend your whole [ __ ] life uh being
smart you have all these passwords that
are rock solid and then this [ __ ]
company just leaks all your information
anyway yeah passport number full address
you're like oh [ __ ] all right well I
didn't want to pay for more security
yeah changing identity I guess yeah
because there's been a few cases where
like full-on like full passport House
address have been leaked yeah yeah was
it the insurance database In America
which one leaked like
tens of millions of like passport
numbers house addresses full-on
information yeah wow you really couldn't
have uh really couldn't have been just a
Cinnabon account or something it had to
be had to be the one that really
mattered come on man come on yeah and I
feel especially as well like in Japan as
well like that is just like the coal
scammers especially like have you heard
of like stories about like the call
scammers oh yeah yeah like the ones that
like Target old people and stuff yeah
they're [ __ ] horrible because like
it's called
the me me scam and it's essentially how
it works for the most part is like uh
you know these like younger dudes like
you know probably around like hours you
definitely listen trash day yeah yeah
we've talked about trash taste but like
yeah they call up these young guys uh
call you know up these older people and
they just go oh it's me it's me
um I'm in a bit of a situation right now
I need you to dump in some money and
it's unfortunate that these old people
just think like oh well if they're
comfortable enough to just say it's me
yeah and they sound young that must be
my grandson yeah
I'm like okay you know I'll dumping some
money and it got in and it became such a
huge problem in like the late 90s and
early 2000s yeah like there was like
millions millions of like elderly
people's money just taking I'm surprised
any of these banks will transfer
anything bro this yeah it takes like a
year to do that that's how you know the
maybe dedicated that's why banks are so
slow now because they're like how do we
yeah
it's like it's like a business part of a
culture yeah it's a legitimate
transaction you're making or did you
scan this off an old person we won't
know I'll never tell I'll never tell
yeah it's depressing yeah it is
depressing it is but hey [ __ ] scammers
and uh if you spend your time wasting a
scammers time you are the real Jeep you
are the real hero you're the one song
Heroes yeah one scammer time waste one
like
[Music]